(students chattering)
- [Jason] So the name String Theory is
a little bit of a play
on our strings program,
but also is a way to bring
science to the forefront.
In physics string theory
was a way to rationalize
how you can have mutually exclusive worlds
operate at the same
time in perfect harmony.
In education kids need
some rigor in academics,
but also things like innovation
and joy and creativity.
(students clapping)
(bright guitar music)
String Theory Schools is based here
in Center City, Philadelphia.
Some of our overarching design
elements are our pathways,
the passion, our mobile first approach
to technology integration,
and our real world culture.
We began with the idea of
giving students the opportunity
to figure out what type
of learner they are,
and also what type of creative they are.
So in our school model we have
a 90-minute-longer school day
that begins in kindergarten,
and they have seven extra classes:
vocal music, instrumental
music, classical ballet,
French as a foreign
language, creative writing,
visual arts, and science and technology.
- [Teacher] Alright, vinegar's done!
- They have those classes once a week,
and the idea is that in the younger grades
we're nurturing them and seeing
where their strengths are.
- Being exposed to all
the majors at a young age,
you got to feel out where
you fit in the best.
- [Jason] And then by middle school
they choose one of those
subjects as a major,
and then get to spend every
single day in that major.
- [Teacher] You see if
you can use those lines
and incorporate that into your design.
- [Rosemary] We try to really make them
think about what area they're
truly passionate about.
- I love to write, act, and film,
so I chose TV and
broadcasting specifically.
You learn so many different things,
from script writing to being on camera
and being behind the camera.
- [Teacher] Alright, ready,
everybody's still rolling.
- So my major is STEM.
I absolutely fell in love with it.
We did forensics.
We're doing DNA barcoding
and sequencing now.
Do five of the sample, right?
- [Male Student] Yup.
- When I found out you could pick a major
since I love to dance, I picked ballet.
The training's pretty rigorous.
- [Dance Teacher] 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, continue.
- Playing violin every single day
has really taught me time management.
I didn't know how much
work would come along
with being a professional.
- We talk a lot about the
discipline that comes from
doing something everyday and
to really do a deep dive.
- It takes determination.
It takes dedication.
All of those types of skills
are skills that you can also apply
to the academic classroom.
- I get a lot of people saying,
"You just dance everyday."
but we are really focused
on getting our education
and going to dance or
singing, whatever your into.
It's really equal.
- Another overarching design element is
our mobile-first approach
to technology integration.
We know that how students consume
content and create content
is first and foremost through mobile,
so we gave them all iPads that were both
1-to-1 and 24/7 with the
idea that that was gonna be
the primary device for them
to engage with their learning.
- You're learning completely differently.
You're learning off Apple TVs
as opposed to blackboards.
- All of our courses are on iTunes U,
so I'll go to english, click the course.
I'll go to history, I'm
gonna do the same thing.
So it's just nice having
everything in one screen
or our teachers are
constantly getting us to
be creative with our projects
and what apps we use.
- [Teacher] Very nice, so this
I think is the most important part.
- [Jason] Lastly, we have
artists in residence,
scientists in residence,
and entrepreneurs in residence
that really are bringing a real world
perspective to these kids,
all while going about their school day.
- [Teacher] And once
this gets to about 350,
we're gonna start our roast.
- I think just seeing the
professionals in their element
I think it makes it more cool.
All of a sudden it made it real.
It was like, Oh I can
actually do this with my life?
- My teacher here, she's
been dancing her entire life.
She pushes us to be the
best that we can be.
She makes us focused.
- [Dance Teacher] 5, 6, 7, 8
- Some of the biggest
benefits are the creativity
and the innovation that we all have gained
from this environment.
If I didn't have an instrumental class,
or if I didn't have
experience in the Cafe Vine,
I wouldn't have been able to develop
into myself.
- When kids get a chance to do
something they like everyday
they become really well developed kids.
So giving kids an opportunity
to find different ways
to pursue their passion
is really central to our
approach to learning.
- Actors ready?
Sound, Camera?
Action.